and michael just just talk us through
where the battles are currently being
fought in that part of ukraine
uh yes jane this is one of the weeks in
which to understand any one part of the
battle you've got to see the whole
battle space and effectively there are
three battles going on at the moment
in kharkiv in svery donetsk of course
and in kersen and those three spaces are
all related to each other in kharkiv in
the north the ukrainians have been
pushing at the russians that offensive
looked at it as if it had run out of
steam a little bit a week ago but now
they're pushing again it looks as if
that they're pushing up towards the
border with russia and that they've
split uh some of the russian forces more
importantly down in kershan they
launched quite a big offensive about 10
days ago now
and that's an important point kirschen's
the first big city that the russians
captured if the ukrainians take it off
them that would be a big big symbolic
victory and what the ukrainians are
doing they opened up a new front from uh
senator cena vika through david of
bridge right up to uh visico
vissacropilia
which is a front of about 50 miles and
the reports over the weekend is that
around davidev bridge they've crossed
the river inulus this is a small winding
river it goes all the way up through the
area right up through these uh
these towns townships there
and in crossing the river the ukrainians
have given themselves a very good chance
of making progress in a an offensive to
cut round behind the russians and put
some pressure on the russian forces of
reincursion the reason that they think
they might be able to do this it seems
is that the russians may have thinned
out their forces in kershan and further
um east from here in uh malitapol there
are reports that a lot of russian troops
seem to have disappeared from the
roadblocks and the checkpoints in
malitopol so
those
fronts are are developing mainly because
of what is actually happening in severe
donetsk
and what about several nice i mean give
us a little bit more detail about it
we've been talking about it for quite a
few weeks now there's been a lot of
action there what is the latest
yeah this is the the this is the essence
of the whole thing jane it's very
donetsk the russians looked as if they'd
taken more or less the whole of the city
about a week ago the ukrainians looked
as if they were pushing back to
lichishansk which is a normal phased
withdrawal look fairly sensible but last
week they began to cross the river back
again this is the river severo donetsk
which is a very important river the
ukrainians have got at least one bridge
that they can use don't know how much
heavy traffic it can take but they're
able to get across the river and they've
pushed into again into this very darn
yes so there's street fighting going on
there now why the ukrainians doing that
severe donetsk is not the most important
objective it's it's symbolically
important but it's not strategically so
important i think there are two things
going on here in the way that the
ukrainians are thinking about it the
important places are slaviansk and
kramatorsk for control of the rest of
the donbass those two cities slavigames
and kramatorsk are really important the
ukrainians must feel
that the threat to slavians and
kramatowski is not so immediate it gives
them time they don't feel as if they've
got to pull right back to defend those
two cities so they're putting more into
holding the russians in severe donetsk
and i suspect that the reason they're
doing this is because the russians are
so obsessed with this place that they're
pushing all their forces in there that's
why they have thinned their forces
around kharkiv and further south in
malitopol and even incursion and the
fact that the ukrainians are able to as
it were make progress in the north and
the south is partly because they are in
military terms they're pinning the
russians in place by fighting so
fiercely in severe donetsk itself and so
for this next week one suspects that
this whole battlefront will be dictated
by three offensives and two rivers jane
michael thank you